masqué adama diarra effectue les
derniers préparatifs avant d'ouvrir son
bureau de vote dans la capitale malienne
un second tour des élections
législatives organisées malgré la
pandémie tout dispositif 100 g les
masses de ligue 1 il faut dire que
l'enjeu est de taille
renouveler un parlement élu en 2013 dont
le mandat devait s'achever en 2018 mais
aussi faire avancer l'application de
l'accord de paix d'alger signés en 2015
entre les groupes armés indépendantistes
et bamako
celui ci prévoit plus de
décentralisation via une réforme
constitutionnelle devant passer par
l'assemblée
sur 147 députés 22 ont été lues
directement au premier tour le 29 mars
dernier
parmi eux soumaïla cissé le principal
opposant au président ibrahim boubacar
kéïta kidnappé le 25 mars dans le nord
du pays par des hommes armés et si
aucune revendication n'a pour l'heure
été fait
tous les soupçons portent sur un des
groupes djihadistes nombreux dans la
région depuis 2012
la violence frappe quotidiennement
civils et soldats dans le centre et le
nord du pays
les morts se compte par milliers et les
déplacés par centaines de milliers lors
du premier tour des présidents de
bureaux de vote ont été kidnappés
décision de voler ou détruites
un millier de bureaux sur vingt-deux
mille n'avait d'ailleurs pas ouvert
ce ne sont pas les élections
controversées contrairement à ce qu'on
dit
ils ont des élections pour laquelle nous
avons souhaité tous participer
l'ensemble de la classe politique à
l'unanimité pour justement
ce déstabiliser la démocratie dans notre
pays et surtout faire en sorte que les
institutions puissent continuer à
fonctionner et qu'il n'y a pas une prise
la politique ou institutionnel
la monture nul de ses amis qui le taux
de participation d'environ 35% lors du
premier tour risque d'être encore plus
faible alors que les premiers résultats
provisoires sont attendus en début de
semaine